and thank you for joining us for the
news here noon everyone i'm alex backus
we do begin with that breaking news this
hour
the cashman center announced just a
short time ago it is closing down its
vaccination mega site we have kate
houston there live at the center
with the latest on this announcement
kate what can you tell us
yes alex well cashman is going to be
closing down its mass vaccination site
on may 5th
that's less than three weeks from now
now the health district says
there have been less people coming to
get vaccines at these large sites
but they say that usually happens after
the initial rush of each tier becoming
eligible
the health district will start to
transition staff from cashmen to the
convention center
they'll also use extra resources and
staffing for many strike teams and
vaccine pods around the county
these will help reach communities that
have yet to be vaccinated
and will service about 300 to 400 people
a day
there's no word yet on where exactly
those will be the health district says
at this point they've gone through the
groups of people
that are comfortable with big sites and
now they need to do a more
targeted approach the health district
says this has been the plan for some
time
on may 5th only second doses will be
administered now people
getting their first dose at cashman over
the next few weeks
will be able to schedule their second
dose at the convention center
we're going to have more coming up
tonight at four o'clock for now
reporting live kate houston 8 news now